tiens quand les 1000 bonjour facteur
salut factor sera pour sûr je n'en
reviens pas c'est vrai j'y croyais vous
trouvez rouillé désespérée même et puis
non je vous trouve la cause en gentiment
comme si rien ne s'était passé j'avoue
que je ne comprends pas écoutez secteur
c'est nous qui ne comprenons absolument
rien ce que vous nous raconter pourquoi
serions-nous désespéré je sens que je
vais être obligé de vous l'annoncer vous
savez que ça ne me plaît pas beaucoup
d'annoncés les mauvaises nouvelles et
bien les y quand même secteur à l'est
dit que le courage
je dois le dire je vais le dire casimir
a quitté l'île aux enfants aujourd'hui
c'est ça qui vous inquiète
pas pour sur votre calme me laisse sans
voix l'écouté facteur c'est la toute
dernière n'est ni de casimir depuis que
léonard a élu domicile chez lui à chaque
dispute il quitte l'île aux enfants pour
toujours et il revient par le même
bateau j'aime autant que vous le preniez
comme ça mais cette fois ci c'est
beaucoup plus sérieux c'est vrai casimir
avait trois mâles il est passé à la
caisse d'epargne parents tout son argent
et il m'a dit je m'en vais je pars en
vacances pour de très longues vacances
même est il mal elle ajouté je vais
passer prendre un billet à l'âge aux du
rennes ça c'est plus inquiétant pour sur
l' agence du rêve ça ressemble à ces
agences de voyage qui proposent des
vacances tout organisé dans des pays
n'ait rien à chercher bien cela oui mais
comment at il pu connaître cette agence
havas il m'a dit que c'était michel
qu'il en avait parlé michèle de chopin
mais il est dans lignes sûrement c'est
formidable
tiens le voilà à l'échelle
vos voyages du cône est le facteur qui
campagne concours sur bonjour bonjour
michel dont michel qu'est ce que c'est
que cette histoire
oriane spéciale je les rencontre est
tout à l'heure mais cette agence du rav
c'est une bonne agence ou moi meuh non
voyants lagence du rêve c'est le petit
d'une de mes chansons
voilà
vous allez je vous la chante oh bah oui
mais bon tiers j'appelle les enfants les
enfants venez venez écouter la chanson
de michel valery venez tous
[Musique]
dans l'aube le départ ma
opposé
dans une île soulevant
que l'on voit le paradis des enfants
je sais
je prends des clients
deux agences rev e
et je fais en chantant
mais
en chantant
ambiance
propice
pour l'amour pour l'avs ne rien faire
la vie sans artifice
simplement coup le rythme de la main
quand je fais la trappe
je prends le déplie en
lagence du bras
et je pèse en chantant
en
chantant
là
non
[Musique]
tha
moore va
manas
non
[Musique]
toi petit dans la grand ville
perdue je tu ils auraient pu aller
vers ce paradis tranquille
pourrait enfin se retrouver
[Musique]
et prend le pli
de l'agencé rev e
et puis vient en chantant
[Applaudissements]
en chantant
non
la main
salut michel à bientôt
mais dites moi oui 6 à 15 ans dure elle
n'existe que dans la chanson
casimir ne veut pas l'avoir trouvé c'est
vrai ça et comme ça dès ce soir nous
allons voir revenir casimir par le
prochain bateau pour sûr je mieux ça et
comme je le dis souvent l'île aux
enfants sont casimir c'est assez pas
tout à fait l'île aux enfants d'avoir
certainement facteurs
en signe d'allégresse je vais vous avez
une limonade idées aux ailes malchance
mais alors quel match à
regarder kazimi et ben il a pas l'air de
très bonne humeur au casimir qu'aspire
raconte nous un petit peu les amis
quelle malchance qui n'a pas trouvé
lagence dieu merci mais son nom comme il
existe vraiment une agence qui s'appelle
la jose dur et bien sûr elles existent
sur ses trois as
que s'est il passé et bien je leur
apporter tout mon argent en leur
demandant des vacances les plus longues
pour le plus bel endroit du monde et que
tout il donner un billet pour six mois
séjours gratuits dans l'île aux enfants
[Musique]